pour dennis c'est devenu une habitude
tous ces déchets de table et les met
dans son bac brun moi je mets 10 h en
train de faire pour l'environnement
c'est important parce que ça va pas dans
les sites d'enfouissement pour que
l'ensemble des citoyens plus faire comme
elle d'ici cinq ans on doit en faire
plus
le gouvernement du québec met en place
une stratégie pour que toutes les
municipalités instaure la collecte des
matières organiques pour que tous les
citoyens et aux bacs bruns d'ici 2025
c'est que ceux-ci l'ambitieux ce qui est
dommage c'est qu'on a quelques années de
retard d'un site dans cette approche-là
le ministre veut que le pourcentage de
matières organiques récupère et passe de
30 à 70% d'ici dix ans il espère ainsi
réduire de moitié la quantité de déchets
organiques envoyés dans des sites
d'enfouissement est diminué par le fait
même les gaz à effet de serre au niveau
nos émissions de gaz à effet serre le
secteur des déchets c'est quand même de
5e secteur en importance on évoque les
réductions l'équivalent de 70 mille
véhicules sur nos routes à travers ce
qui est annoncé aujourd'hui pour
atteindre les objectifs québec vont
injecter 1 milliard 200 millions de
dollars au cours des dix prochaines
années soit 120 millions par année pour
soutenir les municipalités
je pense que ça va nous permettre de
mettre en place des infrastructures y
aura du compostage de la
biométhanisation et sans cette aide
c'est pas possible de mettre en place
les infrastructures nécessaires pour
atteindre les objectifs assez con pour
diminuer notre enfouissement puis à les
faire plus de compass ce qui devrait
être une économie est sûre en bout de
ligne pour tout le monde et un gain
environnemental énorme
selon cet écologiste ou si c'est un gain
on met aussi beaucoup l'accent sur
trouver des débouchés aux affaires
organique parce que c'est bien beau
collecter des matières mais si on sait
pas quoi faire avec on n'est pas plus
avancé donc le fait qu'on va faire de la
recherche et de développement pour
trouver des débouchés aux compresse
qu'on va générer
pour accélérer le virage le gouvernement
du québec va aussi augmenter les
redevances qui doivent être payés pour
l'enfouissement des déchets ici jean
philippe revient à radio canada montréal